Narrator:
This is the Shark Tank,
where entrepreneurs
seek an investment
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
I'm not walking out of here
again without a deal.
Narrator: If the Sharks hear
a great idea...
Are you making these
by hand?
...they'll invest
their own money...
I can get you customers
for this.
I'll give you the same offer
as Kevin.
Narrator: ...and fight
each other for a deal.
How could you guys
be so gullible?
Mark, can I just
listen to him?
You can't be that stupid,
Robert.
The entrepreneurs must get
the full amount
they're asking for, or they'll
walk away with nothing.
I'm definitely
bootstrapping.
You are such a con artist.
And tonight it gets bloodier
than ever in the Tank.
You're working for me
to make money.
-I can't work with you.
-Why not?
-Uh...
-It's the person.
It's the person.
Get the [bleep] out of here.
Oh!
Narrator:
Who are the Sharks?
They're self-made
business experts worth billions.
Kevin O'Leary is
a shrewd venture capitalist
who made his fortune
selling a children's
educational company
for over $4 billion.
Barbara Corcoran went from
waiting tables in Manhattan
to building the city's premier
$2 billion real-estate empire.
Robert Herjavec, son of
an immigrant factory worker,
founded one of
the world's preeminent
cyber-security firms.
Lori Greiner, the Queen of QVC,
holds over 100 patents
and has launched
more than 400 products,
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in sales.
And Mark Cuban,
esteemed billionaire tech mogul
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
First up is an entrepreneur
from Season 4
returning to the Tank with a new
opportunity for the Sharks.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Aaron Marino,
and I'm here today seeking
a $100,000 investment
for 10% equity stake
in my new company,
Pete and Pedro.
So, if I look familiar to you,
it's because
I've been here before,
but last time, I was pitching
the Alpha M style system...
-a.2, b.2!
-Oh, yeah.
...a solid idea, but at $300
a pop for a fashion formula,
customers just didn't bite...
-Shocking.
-...and neither did you.
Thank God.
But you gave me something
more valuable --
a new direction
and life-changing advice.
You see, I knew you were right.
I needed a lower-price-point
product,
something that every guy needed
and used.
Well, about a month after
I was on "Shark Tank,"
there I am styling my hair
when inspiration struck,
and Pete and Pedro was born --
a new line of super-awesome
men's hairstyling products.
Pete and Pedro
equals bueno hair.
We're selling direct
to the consumer,
which means a higher-quality
product at a great price.
Guys buy it, they try it,
they love it,
and sign up
for the Bueno Hair Club,
where we automatically ship them
their favorite
Pete and Pedro product
every four, six, or eight weeks.
Look, Sharks, I'm back,
this time with a product
that men need and love,
and I'm not walking out of here
again without a deal,
so who's ready to partner
with me and share the hair?
[ Laughter ]
All right. So, I've got
some samples for you guys.
Cuban: Notice there's
only four, Kevin.
[ Laughter ]
I have six different
styling aids
and a shampoo and conditioner.
Smells delicious --
like lime and lemon.
Yeah, it's actually like
a freshly bathed tiger.
Yours did?
Aaron, let me ask you
a question.
Mine didn't.
Let me ask you a question.
You're in a very exclusive club,
you realize this.
I am.
The number of people that get
back in the Tank is very small,
so I'd like to know, how fast
did the other one go to zero?
Uh, here's the thing.
It was, uh...
[ Laughter ]
So, I was super excited, right?
I didn't get a deal.
I was like, "No problem.
I'm still gonna be
on national TV.
I'm on 'Shark Tank,' baby,
where dreams are made."
[ Laughs ]
You know how many style systems
I sold the first day
that "Shark Tank" aired?
One.
Aaron, let's -- let's call it
what it was.
Basically,
the Sharks were right.
-It was poo-poo on a stick.
-Your idea went to zero.
-And it was -- it was...
-But great entrepreneurs
understand failure is part
of the success path.
Now you have a new deal.
Why is this one
not gonna go to zero,
is what I want to find out.
Marino: Because I'm already
ahead of the game.
This is a $1 million company
that I've built in two years.
It's making $1 million in sales
right now?
Yeah -- right at $800,000.
-What are sales this month?
-$55,000.
-Wow.
-Good for you.
-Sorry. Sorry.
-And I'm growing --
And I'm growing at 15%
per month.
How did you do that?
I am a YouTuber.
I talk about grooming, I talk
about style, I talk about hair.
How many followers
do you have?
Um, right now I'm at 600,000.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
I get 5.5 million views a month
on my Alpha M YouTube channel
and my website.
I'm a savage on social media.
Greiner:
You're hilarious.
But what is the secret sauce?
Marino:
The products themselves.
Each and every one
of my products
is a rock star
in the respective category.
You post a video,
you're gonna
talk about some grooming
element, right?
-Yeah.
-You're getting ready to go out.
You show how you put the pomade
or the putty,
and you demonstrate the product,
basically, right?
And how many videos do you post
like that?
Wait, wait, wait.
No, no, no, no.
I just want to know
if it's every day.
-Let me -- Let me go through it.
-Okay.
And don't wave your hand
down on me.
I don't like it.
Cut it out. Go ahead.
-Ooh!
-Kids! Kids!
-Come on.
-Shark fight.
Okay, so, how many views
does it get?
In the first 24 hours,
it'll get around 75,000.
I have a 9% conversion rate
when they go directly to...
-Very high.
-I don't believe it.
No, I-I get --
Okay, I get that.
-9%?
-9%.
That's unheard of.
All my numbers
are unheard of.
Not for YouTube.
Do you get paid for those,
or you're just selling
the product?
I get paid by YouTube.
I also get paid
by these brands.
JC Penney sponsored a makeover
series that I do.
I've done a video for Chevrolet
for the new Corvette.
Um, I'm talking to
a few other big brands now.
I mean, I've promoted everything
from underwear
to Bombas socks --
Remember them?
I am approached
by everybody.
How much money do you get
out of that?
I'm just wondering
how much comes
from you being paid
as a great salesman...
Yeah.
...and how much is from
the actual product sale.
Two separate -- I've got
two different businesses.
How much did you bring in --
just out of curiosity...
From the other business?
As talent -- As talent
as an "endorser."
Uh, from my Alpha M,
I did $600,000 last year.
-Wow.
So, is that part of the deal
you're offering us?
-So, how do you split your time?
-No, it's not.
-And here's why, Barbara.
-That's the problem.
Marino:
I'll tell you why.
No, it's not,
but let me tell you why.
-It's a big problem.
-I have no -- No, it's not,
because what I have
is credibility,
and the moment that I have
somebody else's money
on the line
basically determines --
Cuban: It's not that
this is a bad product,
but it's you selling it.
The real product is you.
This just happens to be what
you're selling right now.
Aaron, there's no other way
to do it,
because how do you allocate
your time?
If I give you $100,000
for 10%...
Mm-hmm.
...of the, uh,
the donkey deal...
[ Greiner laughs ]
...why would I want you spending
any time doing anything else?
Because it's the way that social
media and influencers work.
Here's the thing.
This is my full-time job,
but another part of this
is me creating content,
engaging with people.
Why would I want one
of my entrepreneurs
spending any time doing anything
else except making me rich?
Why would I do that?
It's a byproduct of me
doing what I do.
-No, it isn't.
-Sure it is.
Put them together --
You put them together,
and then every dime you
bring in, I get 10% of it.
That's how it should work.
You're working for me
to make money.
-How appetizing.
-That's what I want.
-I bet you can't wait.
-Yeah. That sounds great,
but let me...
-[ Laughs ]
...just for a second --
Here's how we're gonna
scale this.
I'm an influencer.
-I don't care.
Well, you should care, because
it's worth millions of dollars!
If I give you money,
I'm your investor.
You think I want you
doing anything else
for anybody else,
if I give you money?
Cuban: So, if you decide
to build this
to be the next
Paul Mitchell, right,
you're gonna be the face,
you're gonna be doing
everything,
and you're gonna
be promoting,
but they've got to be
the same thing.
They go hand in hand.
I understand that.
I appreciate that.
-All right, Aaron.
I'm willing to make you
an offer, okay?
So let's just --
This is my first offer
in the Tank!
-Well, there you go.
-There you go.
You might regret it.
-Here's the deal --
Alpha M merges with mini donkey,
all right?
The two of them
come together.
-Okay.
-Because I want you full time.
I give you the $100,000
for 20%,
and I help you
as much as I can,
drive as much traffic
as I can,
'cause that's actually
how it works.
That's the deal.
What do you say to my offer?
♪♪
Narrator: Kevin O'Leary has
offered Aaron $100,000 for 20%,
but he wants Aaron to combine
his Pete and Pedro
hair product company
and his lucrative
social-media business, Alpha M.
What do you say to my offer?
I say that it's, uh --
it's -- it's -- it's a haircut.
[ Chuckles ]
I think you're a great
personality,
and I can see why you do so well
on YouTube.
For me, I don't -- I don't get
why this is fantastic.
For me, I don't think this is
the right product, so I'm out.
I understand.
Thank you.
What you've proven since
you were here last time
is that you can drive traffic.
What you happen to be driving
traffic to is this product,
and people are buying it.
But there's other products.
Like, if I invest
in this product
and you come out
with a hairbrush...
-Then there's another --
-...just as an example.
Yeah.
Is that part of
the mini donkey,
or is that part
of Alpha M?
Like, whi-which one?
And if your loyalty
is split,
you're gonna go to where
you make the greatest
amount of profit.
It's all got
to be one thing.
-It's one business.
-So make me an offer, Robert.
I'm here to make a deal,
because I need help, honestly.
Well, you got to combine
the two.
Okay.
You're the product,
and the thing you're peddling
is enthusiasm and confidence,
and there's nothing
more magnetic
in any business field
than that quality,
and you've got it.
I don't think you need
any of our help, frankly,
on building your following,
doing social media.
But what you don't know is what
I know inside and out
for building a business
for 30 years.
I know structure,
organization,
when to hire who,
who to fire.
I know all that,
'cause I've made every damn
mistake out there.
I'll offer you $100,000 for 10%
of your Alpha M
social media business.
That's it.
♪♪
I want a piece
of everything you do.
For $100,000, I want 20%,
because I add
so much more value.
Yeah, and the value
he's gonna add, trust me,
is he's gonna make
you feel miserable
every day of your life.
Herjavec: I'll give you
the same offer as Kevin,
because I don't think Kevin
adds anything to this.
I'll give you the $100,000 for
20% of the combined business.
O'Leary: Okay.
You've been offered
three different deals.
What do you want to do?
Okay, Kevin,
I appreciate your offer,
but then,
if it makes it easier...
Why don't you just reject him?
He doesn't get it.
I'm gonna, you know,
say "thank you,"
but I'm not going to
accept your offer.
-Why, Aaron?
-It's too much,
and I don't feel you bring
the value that I need.
Aaron, sorry,
do you have a counter?
-Do you have a counter
for the amount of money?
-I wouldn't do it for less.
[ Laughs ] Um...
10% of everything --
Ooh, God.
Um...$300,000 for -- for 10%.
Corcoran:
Yeah, I'll tell you what --
I'll give you half the money
if you get somebody else
in the deal.
Mark, do it.
Bring on the social-media help.
Yeah, but I'm -- there's just
not enough there for me, Aaron.
Okay.
I just think I bring
too much value,
but I think any of these guys
would be great,
but I'm out.
Okay.
You're always gonna be the face
of the brand.
I'm interested in using
your platform
to move other products.
So, how about this?
I'll give you $100,000 for 10%
of any products.
Today, starting with
the little donkey.
Tomorrow, there will be
a sweater, a pocket square.
There will be other products.
As people pay you for promotion,
you -- you keep that money,
but I see you as a platform
to sell other products
that men struggle with.
-Here's where that gets
complicated.
-Doesn't work.
Is because I need
my authenticity
and I still have the ability
to say "no."
If you're my partner
and you're saying, "Hey..."
-You still --
"...here's the next product,"
and I've got to partner
with you.
-Aaron -- No, no, no, no.
Hang on. Aaron --
-You've got to combine it.
-You can't -- You can't sell --
-Barbara -- Hold on.
Barbara, that 10% of Alpha M,
$100,000 -- You good?
-Yes.
Aaron...
-Let's do it.
-[ Laughs ]
-You're a smart guy.
You've got great judgment,
you're good-looking.
Hey, come on!
And we're gonna have
kids together.
-[ Laughs ]
-Thank you so much.
-Thank you.
-That's awesome. Mm!
-Thank you. My pleasure.
♪♪
So, I made a deal with Barbara
but not for the company
I went in to pitch.
I'm like, "Seriously."
I'm like, "I've got
such a good product here.
It's gonna make a lot of money,
but you don't want it?
"You want me? Okay.
I'll sell me. Let's do this."
I don't think you know
what you bought.
I certainly do.
I know what I saw there.
This guy's a moneymaker,
and he's already fast
on that road,
and I'm going for the ride.
-I would've never done
that deal that way.
Good luck, Barbara.
Narrator:
It's been another monumental
season of "Shark Tank."
Man:
Ladies and gentlemen,
the President of
the United States.
[ Applause ]
President Obama:
Welcome to the White House.
We have a lot
of brainpower here.
We even got a few Sharks.
"Shark Tank's" become
an American phenomenon,
and us being here, the support
of the president,
just goes to show you
that the American dream
is alive and well,
and I think "Shark Tank"
has a lot to do with that.
Narrator: We've seen the power
of the Sharks...
I pronounce you man and wife.
I invested in these companies.
Now we're building our future
on the Something Wonderful
platform.
We're gonna grow this to
the hundreds of millions.
I brought celebrity chef
Rocco DiSpirito here.
I have big plans
for these companies,
and they're gonna take
their businesses
to an entirely new level.
Welcome to paradise!
I'm so proud of each
of my entrepreneurs.
They all work like crazy to make
their dreams come true.
Who wouldn't love
a Shrek slipper?
Man: DreamWorks Animation
has reached out
about a licensing opportunity.
With Robert on board,
we have credibility now
that we could've never achieved
without him.
Narrator: ...and huge sales.
So proud of all of you.
Since I've invested, combined
sales are $188 million.
[ Air horn blows ]
Man: We've expanded
to 28 cities,
and our attendance has exploded.
We've had $10.5 million
in sales.
Man #2:
We've grown to 12 employees,
and we've done $2 million
in sales.
Man #3: We've gone from
one employee to over 20,
and we've done over $10 million
in sales.
We finished the year
over $14 million in sales.
Man #4: We started
with one food truck.
We now have 18 throughout
the country.
Our total sales are $15 million.
Narrator:
And "Shark Tank" entrepreneurs
are changing lives
around the world.
-Are you guys all ready to play?
-Yeah!
Woman:
Because of "Shark Tank,"
we've been able to get
our toys to girls
who will one day
build our future.
Man #5: I want to make sure
we have a healthy supply
of food and water
for future generations.
If we can have more positive
impact on more children's lives,
that's our
company's mission.
Woman #2:
As young women in business,
it's an incredibly
humbling feeling
to be able to do what we do and
inspire others in the process.
We're so grateful
for our experience
and know that our future
is brighter than ever
with the help of "Shark Tank."
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a healthy
snack geared towards women
when they need it the most.
♪♪
[ Sighs ]
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Tania.
I'm from Boston.
And I'm seeking $50,000
for 20% of my company.
I know. I don't look excited
to be here at all.
[ Laughter ]
I am on the inside.
It's just that my back
is killing me,
I have a splitting headache,
I'm so bloated,
this dress may pop off,
and I'm exceptionally hot.
That's right, Sharks.
I'm talking about PMS.
90% of women suffer from one or
more of the 150 symptoms of PMS,
and those symptoms can last
an average of 7 to 10 days
out of the month.
Think about that number,
Mr. Wonderful.
That's a third of your year
where you'd be crankier
than usual.
[ Chortles ]
But I have a solution --
PMS Bites.
PMS Bites are delicious
and healthy bite-size snacks
specifically designed for women
when we need them most.
They're made with all-natural,
vegan,
and gluten-free ingredients,
and they contain a blend
of herbs
that women commonly take
for bloating,
cramping, and irritability.
PMS Bites are the perfect snack
to help women take
those 122 days back
and satisfy cravings
without guilt.
Sharks, who's ready to take
the bite out of PMS?
Greiner: We all are.
[ Laughs ]
-And I have samples for you.
-We're ready to try them!
-Okay.
-That's what I mean.
Herjavec: What's the most
common symptom, Tania?
-I would say irritability.
-Lori,
we know you need it.
-Oh, Robert.
-Wow.
-Thank you.
[ Light laughter ]
Oh, I love the packaging.
Look at the package --
very cute.
The main ingredients are dates,
almond butter,
and gluten-free oats.
Herjavec:
These are really good.
-Great candy. It's great.
-Thank you.
They're 50 calories each.
-They're pretty good.
-They're very good.
Thank you very much.
How many have you sold?
So, I have $13,400.07
in sales.
-[ Laughs ]
-Can you be a little
more specific?
How do you get the 7 cents
in sales?
Every penny counts, Mark.
[ Chuckles ]
I have been selling
for two months
and executing my retail strategy
for two months.
How long did it take you
to have $13,000 in sales?
Uh, seven months ago.
Herjavec:
What kind of stores?
Retail --
independent retailers.
Are you making these by hand?
I've made 7,500 bites
by hand.
-In your kitchen?
-Um, no.
I have a commercial kitchen.
Why isn't it selling?
Oh...
Yeah, Tania, you're the queen
of small numbers.
♪♪
It's not a lack of interest
in the market.
It's a lack of funding.
I'm a one-woman show.
So I'm pitching
to retailers,
I'm making them,
I'm packaging them,
I'm delivering them
on my bike.
Um...
Why did you
come up with this?
Oh, I would get
debilitating PMS.
It was horrible.
But this is not a medicinal
ingredient for PMS.
It's just a...a bon bon,
right?
Greiner: Well, you were
saying there's herbs in it
that women take to help PMS.
-Yes.
How do you know it actually
offsets the symptoms of PMS?
It can't.
What I'm saying is, this is
a healthy alternative
for women to any fatty,
sugary food out there.
Cuban:
For cravings.
The downside to naming it
PMS Bites, because,
you know, I'm a guy.
I like dates,
but calling it
PMS Bites is --
I'm not gonna reach on the shelf
and buy that.
She's not looking --
No, she doesn't want --
-You're not the target market.
-But that's not my passion.
-You're not her customer.
-But you cut your market
in half.
Greiner: Well, let me
ask you a question.
Couldn't you take and make these
for everybody...
Absolutely.
...call them something else,
but on your website,
you could put "This is great
for women with PMS"?
If I named it
"Tania's Vegan Cookies,"
I wouldn't be in front
of you today.
Yeah, you're one
of everybody.
-Right?
-Well, but...
-Good point.
It's a marketing play
is what it is.
I have a ton of
testimonials saying,
"I feel better
when I eat them.
I now have a product that I can
crave and enjoy
and not feel
guilty afterwards."
-And it's healthier. Right.
-And it's healthier.
Dates and brown rice
are extremely low
on the glycemic index,
which means it's not gonna
cause a spike
in your blood-sugar levels
and then leave you
crashing later.
Sugar is the worst thing
a woman
can put into her body
when she's PMS'ing.
It exacerbates
your symptoms.
-Tell us your background.
-Yeah.
What makes you an expert
at cookies?
I went into
two consulting firms
and led their marketing
departments
and branding departments
and was not passionate about
selling somebody else's dream.
This is something that
I'm passionate about,
I use for me, and I know
that women will love it.
Nobody's asked
what these cost.
So, they wholesale for $4.50
to retailers.
-For three of them.
-For three?
For three.
That's correct.
It costs me $1.55 to make,
so my margin's 66%.
That means they're getting
retailed for what?
$7?
-That's correct.
What kind of a store?
Think of juice bars --
juice bars at high-end gyms
like Equinox.
-I see.
-You have these at Equinox?
I do. I have them at all
Massachusetts Equinox.
-And are they selling through?
-Yes.
Is there a vegan truffle-like
ball that does not have sugar,
that does not have flour
and things like that in it?
I mean, do you have competition
out there?
So, my main competition
is any unhealthy product
that women crave.
Direct competitors --
There's nobody adding herbs
to the blend.
You know, there are three things
I think about
when I look at a product.
Is it something people
need and want?
Can it be made
at an affordable price?
And is there a broad
mass audience for it?
Right?
But if you're marketing it
as a PMS Bite,
you just lost half the market --
You lost children, you lost men.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
I love the marketing slogan,
and I disagree with Lori...
-Okay.
...because I think there's
so much noise out there
in this
healthy-food category.
You stand out
because you're unique.
But you're talking about
hundreds of dollars,
as Kevin says.
The numbers
are just so small.
I'm out.
I feel like you need,
um, somebody else
joined with you at your hip
to really push this thing.
I don't see you
selling this.
I don't feel that energy,
that drive.
Barbara, respectfully,
I have so much energy.
I have been pushing this
from day one.
I'll have to take you
on face value.
I hear the words,
not the music.
I am out.
Tania, I'm sorry.
You are the princess
of small numbers,
and you have to become the queen
of monster sales.
It's too small for me.
I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you.
Mark, have you decided?
Cuban: Look, this is all about
social media.
Where you go
on social media
is gonna make or break
the product.
What are you doing there?
So, retail and online
is gonna be super important,
but I made the decision
to be strictly focused
on the retail side
so that I could perfect
the sales pitch,
control the sales cycle.
I think you made
a strategic mistake
in focusing specifically
on retail.
This is such
a viral product.
This is about "people talking
to each other" type product.
It's inconceivable to me that
you didn't focus online to sell,
particularly
coming into here.
And the one big upside
isn't to drive people into
Equinox gyms in Boston.
-Right.
-You know?
It's online, and so that
makes me question things.
And to do this, it would
have to be an investment,
not tuition, and it feels
more like tuition,
so for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you.
♪♪
I feel like I have a lot
of work to do,
but they loved the product,
and I know that women will be
able to enjoy them,
and I'm just gonna work
so much harder.
♪♪
My name is Tomer Alpert,
and I'm from Telluride,
Colorado.
I live here with
my wife, Gracie,
and our new baby boy, Leo.
It's very realistic.
As people get more dependent
on their devices,
they still crave a personal way
to connect with each other.
Our product blends convenience
with thoughtfulness,
allowing people to share
the way they feel
with the people
they care about most.
How you doing, buddy?
I haven't brought a paycheck
home in four years.
My wife and I have both been
working on it full time,
and we're literally out of cash.
When I think about my family
and the business,
I almost can't believe
what I'm doing.
So much is at risk -- not only my future,
but their future, as well.
It's now about my son
and his ability to have college
and a future.
It feels like the most
enormous pressure
I've ever been under in my life.
Frank Frank, let's go!
Having a Shark on board would
validate every decision
I've ever made for the business.
It would give us the cash I need
to pay rent and to keep
the business afloat.
[ Smooching ]
My family's put so much faith
in me, I can't let them down.
I hope a Shark will join me
and help spread the love.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name's Tomer Alpert.
I'm from Telluride, Colorado,
and I'm seeking $200,000
for 6% of our company, Felt.
Think about how wonderful
it feels
to receive a handwritten card
in the mail,
knowing that your friend
picked the card just for you.
And they took time
to handwrite you
a personal, thoughtful message.
-Hm.
-Great experience, right?
Now think about sending the
card -- terrible experience.
You have to drive to the store,
pick a card from a giant wall,
drive home, write your message,
search for stamps,
and still have to trek out
to the mailbox.
So it's no wonder we don't send
more handwritten cards.
That's why we built Felt.
Now you can send an authentic,
handwritten card
from your phone or tablet
anywhere, anytime.
Here's how it works.
Simply download Felt
from the app store,
pick the card for your occasion,
then handwrite your message
right on the screen.
You can use your finger
or a stylus.
Address the envelope,
and we print, seal, stamp,
and mail the card for you.
It is that simple.
-Pretty cool.
-Thank you.
Now, we're not only making
card-sending simpler.
We also make it better,
because with Felt,
you can add up to three photos
to your card,
and you can even add a short
handwritten message
to each of them.
And we built Felt
'cause we want everyone
to be able to be the heartfelt,
thoughtful person
they really are.
So join us, Sharks, and let's
spread love around the world.
I'd love to give you each
a handwritten card
I wrote you using Felt.
Would this be exactly
how I would get it?
-Exactly how you'd get it.
-Hm.
Do you have some photos in there
we can see, too?
-Thank you, Tomer.
-I do.
So, everybody's gonna get
a different card.
-Thank you, Tomer.
-Thank you.
Each card will be a sample of
what you can do from the app.
-Thanks, Tomer.
-You're welcome. Thank you.
Ohhh.
-Which one did you get?
-I got the bulldog.
That's one of our
best-selling cards.
So, Felt is actually
a marketplace
for designers
to sell their cards,
which is a big part
of our strategic plan.
Oh.
That's interesting.
Tomer,
can I upload my own JPEG?
-Yes.
-And does it stay in my account?
Am I building an account
for myself?
-Yes.
All of your sentimental mail
you send, we at Felt --
your handwritten card,
your photos --
get saved in the app...
-Yep.
...and you can come back
to them and see them.
You can also resend them and edit them
and change people's names.
I've got, uh,
an engagement party,
and I've got 88 people coming.
Can I build an invitation
and then load in the addresses
and then do a mass mailing?
So, we don't do
invitations yet,
but that's where
we're heading,
because what you can do in Felt
is you can save every single
address you write.
So, let's say you're a bride.
-Yeah.
Brides do 75 thank-you cards,
on average,
and they handwrite
every address.
Now in Felt,
you get saved addresses,
so when you want
to do invitations
or holiday cards next year,
all your addresses
are handwritten.
How long have you been
in the app store?
Since May 2013.
And how many downloads?
Over 60,000, and we have
a 4.5-star rating
across both of our apps.
60,000 is nothing,
so that's why you're here.
Right? That's not enough to
build and sustain a business.
And here's why.
So we started selling
a $4 greeting card,
and we're scrappy
entrepreneurs.
We invested all of our own cash
into this.
So I've put in $100,000.
And who's the "we" in this,
Tomer?
There's four partners.
Me, my wife, Gracie --
she does operations.
The reason we're here today
is 'cause we've identified
two huge markets
who have huge problems --
brides and professionals.
A bride already
has the problem.
She or he has to has to send
75 thank-you cards.
So what we want to do is plug in
with registries.
Imagine if you go to Macy's
and you build your registry
and you learn about Felt.
And you're like, "Holy moly."
I-I see what you're doing,
but that's just a one-off, right?
No, no. A bride turns into
a holiday card,
so next year,
she does holiday cards...
Eh...
...and she does the birthday
cards and she does --
I'm just telling you,
because my wife would be,
"Are you kidding me?
You're not willing
to take the time
to really
handwrite them?"
The best tool for women --
guilt.
Yeah.
It's totally authentic --
as if you wrote it
with pen and paper
on your dining-room table.
-Tomer, there's a lot --
-And that's what customers
love about us.
Tomer, isn't there a lot of
people that do this already?
There's nobody else
that lets you
literally handwrite
on the screen.
Everybody else does some sort
of mimicking.
I love to send handwritten cards
as a thank-you.
It's very personal.
I've never gotten a handwritten
thank-you from you, ever.
Well, you've never done
anything that deserved
a thank-you, Barbara.
That's true.
You're right about that.
[ Laughter ]
There's a lot of people
doing this.
There's nothing proprietary
about the technology.
I'm out.
I understand.
Do you know what your
customer-acquisition
cost is now?
-So, for consumers, it's $8.
-Ohh.
And that's why we're focusing
on brides...
Corcoran: Yeah.
...because brides will spend
$210 with us...
-Yeah.
-...and we net $125.
-But you don't have them yet.
-Yes.
I've got four companies
in the wedding business.
You know, I own Honeyfunds.
We have all your
customers already.
-There you go.
-This is a good app for them.
In the marriage space
you want to pursue,
I can get you customers
for this.
I've got them for zero
customer-acquisition cost,
but I want more than 6%.
-[ Laughs ]
-What are you willing to sell?
How much equity are you
willing to sell?
6% doesn't get me up
in the morning.
What would you like to buy?
How much do you need --
How much do you need
to make a deal?
I got to have a minimum --
I got to have a minimum of 10%.
I'll give you $225,000
for 10%...
...and all the brides
you can eat.
You're crazy to say no
to that.
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah. That's...
I'm giving you
free customers.
I'm gonna make it easier --
I'm out.
Thanks, Mark.
I appreciate your time.
I'm gonna make it easier,
because I'm going out,
but I think you should take
an offer from this guy.
-Thank you, Barbara.
-Yeah, I got to have 10%.
I'll give you $225,000 --
And I'll make it easy
for you, too.
I'm out, but I think what
Kevin's offered you here
might bring you just
what you said you wanted,
which was brides.
Thank you very much, Lori.
Tomer, seven seasons,
I've never seen him make
this good an offer.
Seriously.
♪♪
I appreciate it,
Mr. Wonderful.
And I wouldn't do it --
The deal's done!
-Wow!
-Yeah!
-Finally!
This will be --
This will be good for you.
It's a good marriage.
He likes marrying people.
Mm-hmm.
We have to integrate
the platform
of Honeyfund
immediately.
Let's do it.
That's the key.
It's cool.
Thank you.
Thanks, Kevin.
Congratulations, Tomer.
-[ Howls ]
-Wow.
-Congratulations!
-Good job.
Congrats, buddy.
I didn't think Kevin was the
Shark that we were gonna get.
Whaaaat?
I need to go have a cerveza.
I need to go hug my wife!
I can't wait to see her.
[ Voice breaking ] Um...
this has just been a long road.
[ Chuckles ] Thank you.
It was amazing.
Like, he just --
[ Crying and laughing ]
[ Laughs ]
I'm so happy.
I can't believe it.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a unique
way to break bad habits.
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Maneesh Sethi,
and I'm from Boston,
Massachusetts,
and I'm seeking $500,000
in exchange for 3.14%
of my company.
-3.14.
-It's Pi Day!
[ Light laughter ]
Sharks, everybody
has bad habits,
and for some of us,
they're minor --
nail biting,
hitting the snooze button.
But for others, they can be much
more serious or even deadly.
Meet Pavlok, the first wearable
that doesn't just track
what you do,
but actually changes
what you do.
Pavlok helps you become aware
by alerting you
when you do behaviors
you'd like to reduce,
then simply press the button
and Pavlok releases
a mild electric sensation...
that helps you reduce
cravings --
[ Laughter ]
You can laugh, but it's actually
something very serious.
I am laughing.
Maneesh: It releases
a mild electric sensation
that helps you reduce cravings
and actually breaks bad habits
in the brain.
Pavlok harnesses
scientific methods
that have been researched
for decades,
but it's not just research.
Since launch, our users have had
incredible success
in changing their behaviors.
Now, Sharks, which of you wants
to join us in our mission
to help people across the globe
take control
of their own behavior?
How did you come up
with this idea?
I've always had severe ADD.
I could never get myself
to actually get stuff done.
I couldn't get myself to commit
to anything,
so I did what any normal person
would do --
I hired someone to sit down
next to me
and slap me in the face every
time I went on Facebook.
-Nice.
-[ Chuckles ] Yeah.
And I wrote a blog post
about it.
-Why not?
-Seriously?
[ Chuckling ] Yeah.
It's a cool video.
And the blog post
went insanely viral.
-Did they actually slap you?
-Yeah.
There's a video of me
getting slapped.
But did you get
the work done?
I did. Yeah.
It was really cool.
That made you come up
with this idea.
Yeah. I was visiting
a friend of mine.
I'm like, "Dude,
why am I paying?
I could just make a --
make a zapper
that zaps me every time
I go on Facebook.
-Can we try it?
-This is fascinating.
Can we try it?
I'm gonna show it to you
after one moment.
I just want to explain kind of
the science behind it,
and then I'll bring it out
for you.
Pavlok uses a type of science
called aversive conditioning.
It was very common in the 1960s.
It's a slight electric stimulus
that's done while doing
a undesired bad habit,
and it very rapidly trains
your reptile brain
to associate that uncomfortable
stimulus with the bad habit.
Herjavec: This is based
on the Pavlovian principle.
Can you explain that principle
to us?
Sure. So, when you add
two stimuli together
at the same time,
your brain doesn't know
what is causing the stimuli
to occur.
It just knows that they're both
happening at the same time,
and it starts to retreat.
So I'll go ahead
and bring it out for you
right now to try on.
Here you go,
Mr. Herjavec.
-This one?
-Yeah.
Please put it on for me.
It's got your name engraved
on it and everything.
Greiner: Wow.
I like the design of it.
-Thank you, Manny.
-Thank you.
And if you notice...
Mr. Cuban.
-Thank you, sir.
Simply press the lightning bolt
on the top of it.
Press down hard.
-Oh, there you go.
-It's just a little pulse.
Yeah. So,
I set it low for you,
because I didn't want everybody
to get scared.
Can you set it higher?
Yeah. I'll do it right now.
All right.
-Oh!
-Ow! [Bleep]
Turn it back now.
Ow! Wow!
How do you turn it off?
-I barely feel it!
Well, let me come back
to our results, okay?
Okay.
In a study that we based
our first experiment with,
it was an aversive conditioning
study that was done in 1988
with 832 subjects.
So, okay. So wait, so wait.
Let's -- Let's qualify that.
After five days...
You said, "We based our
first study on," right?
Suggesting that...
-In 1988.
...that you did the study,
right? Did you...
So, I'll tell you about a study
we did right after,
but you can actually look
through our evidence pamphlet,
where we have
21 clinical trials.
Herjavec:
I bite my nails.
I'm trying to not bite my nails
all the time.
Where it falls down
for me is
if I have the discipline
to buzz myself,
do I not have the discipline
to stop?
People -- Okay.
People -- Do you have
the discipline to stop?
-Well, I don't, but --
-Do you wish you could stop?
-I do --
-So, can I -- So, here's...
-But your premise is --
-Sorry.
It's all nonsense,
Robert.
It's all nonsense
across the board.
Herjavec: Just --
I-I-I can't get around that.
Like, I'm just --
I want to bite my nails,
and for me to stop,
I have to hit this thing.
Sure.
Why can't Lori
buzz it for me?
She can.
Um, she absolutely can.
There's a remote control --
There's a remote-control app.
There's automation.
What percentage of the time
does it not work?
It doesn't work if you don't
want it to work.
So, it doesn't --
-Oh!
Wow!
-Yeah, of course.
So, if you use it on sugar,
after about three or four days
on, like, a cookie
or tortilla chips,
you'll start to notice
the flavor changes.
Now, what's interesting
about it, in the first --
You start to notice
the flavor changes?
-Yeah, you do.
-You're such a con artist.
I'm absolutely not.
As for results, Mark,
more than 50% of our users
break their habit in five day--
in seven days or less.
First of all, you can't -- First
of all -- Okay, let me just --
Let's leave the skepticism
for one minute.
-No, no, no, no, no, no.
-I just want you to --
I love the skepticism,
'cause he doesn't know
what's about to come.
Because it's all nonsense,
because you can't tell
anything in five days.
You guys can argue
till the cows come home.
You want to get a deal,
explain to me why you're
worth $14 million.
-Sure $15 million.
-What is it? How much?
Well, number one -- number one,
our sales are great.
-What are your sales?!
-What are your sales?
You didn't even
get to that.
So, we're in pre-order,
and we actually just began
shipping this week.
We've sold $800,000 of revenue.
Wait, wait -- preorders.
3/4 of the users
were preorders,
and 1/4 of the users
were prototypes.
What did each of those people
pay for one device?
$200.
How much?
Who buys these?
So, our biggest users
are sitting too long,
waking up on time,
nail biting, and eating.
So we've started to build out
multiple really cool
integrations for this product.
The first thing
is the alarm clock.
It's the first alarm clock
that works.
When you get a slight zap
in the morning,
it actually knocks you awake
with a jolt of adrenaline.
-Great way to start the day.
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah. You'd be surprised.
The people love it.
Can't wait.
How could you guys
be so gullible?
-Read the evidence
if you're that --
-We're not being gullible.
None of it's
your evidence!
We're asking questions.
No one's disputing
aversion therapy.
-Yeah. So, we're --
-Aversion therapy works.
We're bringing aversion therapy
to consumers!
You're using other
people's studies...
But, so, there's nothing
that's actually happening...
Mark, we know you're the
smartest guy in the room...
...besides the...
It's not about being the
smartest guy in the room!
You can't be that stupid,
Robert,
to even think there's
any legitimacy.
-Enough. Calm down.
-Can I just listen to him?
Geez.
Ugh. Gosh, you guys
are making me so ADD.
All right,
let me talk about the...
Oh, we make you ADD?
Maneesh: You guys make it
happen. All right.
Maneesh,
you're a strange dude.
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
Some of the cool stuff
we're doing that Mr. Cuban
would like is this --
We've started integrating
with --
I don't think Mark's
gonna like anything.
Herjavec: Yeah.
Aversion therapy is legit,
but what's not legit
is trying to take credit
for other studies and apply it
to your product.
You're kidding.
I gave you an evidence booklet
with all
the citations, sir.
Greiner:
These are your studies?
You've got a booklet
that has -- None of those
studies are yours!
They're just related
to aversion therapy.
No, no, no, no.
These are studies we -- we --
These are
aversion therapy studies.
Aversion therapy studies,
so -- Okay.
Outside your realm.
Not necessarily --
Oh, well, you know what?
That's -- That's the strongest
point here...
O'Leary:
Hang on. Mark...
...is that this isn't based on
anything that you've done.
-Right!
-Are you negotiating, or --
Okay, so we have had
600 users.
So, where are your studies?
Over half of them quit their
addiction in five days --
seven days or less.
Well, wait. But you don't
have any proof that it
changes your taste buds.
Yes, we do. We do.
We have users. We have evidence.
You don't have any testing.
More than half of
our users quit --
More than 81% of our users quit
nail biting in four days.
Where is your proof of this?
What study do you have?
You should be doing
clinical trials.
-Sure. I'd love to.
-Right?
-They're expensive.
-So, we began --
Why don't you have
clinical trials?
All right,
I'm gonna make it simple.
I talk about things.
I say things are either heroes
or zeroes.
For me, this is
a nowhere-near-o.
I'm out.
I find your presentation is
exhausting and complicated,
and I couldn't imagine having
the energy to deal with that.
This doesn't sound
very positive, Barbara.
I'm out.
Okay, Lori and Barbara
are history.
I'd like to talk a little bit
about our numbers this year.
Let me --
Let me just finish.
Sure.
When you first came out,
I really liked it.
It's habit.
Habit creates discipline,
discipline creates more habit,
and that's how you get success.
What I don't like about is you
have a $16 million valuation
on preorders --
It's too much.
I'm out.
So, I understand
absolutely, Robert.
Thank you very much.
Look, if you had
verifiable proof
that all your
aversion therapy...
Mm-hmm.
...can be well-executed
with your device,
you wouldn't need to import
other people's studies,
because with all this
advance money you got,
you could've gone to any
university and said,
"You know what?
We don't want to rush it.
We want to get our own
verifiable studies in place
so that no one
can question us."
The one thing that kills
tech products is hyperbole...
Mm-hmm.
...because at some point
you have to execute.
You violated that one.
-Let me speak. Listen.
Now your turn to listen.
If you would've just said,
"You know what?
This is a reminder,
and everybody is different,
so we have different ways
to remind you."
Bam.
Right? But you went so
over-the-top with nonsense,
it is everything but
a legitimate product,
and for those reasons,
I'm out.
Let me tell you --
Let me come back to medical,
'cause I really want to answer
Lori's question.
Maneesh, all of these
Sharks are out.
They're all out.
-Kevin's left.
They're all out, okay?
There is a medical component
to this, but I --
Shock yourself
for a minute.
You're a combination of
spontaneous combustion
and ADD mixed together.
-[ Laughs ]
-I'm not kidding.
It's very difficult
to listen to you.
-Yeah.
Luckily for you, I got
my undergrad in psychology.
To make money, I worked
on a rhesus study
that used the same technology
as you to modify behavior.
-[ Laughs ]
-How many other degrees, right?
And I'm telling you
the truth here.
So I'm interested, okay?
Whoa.
♪♪
Narrator:
Four Sharks are out,
but Kevin seems interested
in Maneesh's habit-breaking
watch, Pavlok.
I believe this technology works
'cause I've seen it work.
Your valuation is crazy.
-Okay.
-I'm sorry.
It's not worth
$15.9 million now.
I'm gonna solve the problem
in the deal structure.
I'm very creative.
I'll give you the $500,000
as debt on the company, okay?
You're gonna give me the 3.14%
as equity today,
and you're gonna walk out of
here with a Shark Tank deal.
I'm gonna put it on
for 24 months at 7.5%
and balloon payment me back
in two years.
If 1/3 of your projections are
right, you can easily do that.
-It's an offer!
-It's an offer.
This is the problem.
Um, damn.
-There's a problem?
-There's no problem.
See, the problem,
Mr. Wonderful,
is that we're not focused
on the money.
We're focused more on the habits
we're changing.
Not focused on the money?
You've come to the wrong place,
my friend.
Cuban:
You're focused more on the what?
-I'm here to make money.
-Let him finish, Kev.
Maneesh: Our biggest thing --
Our biggest goal
is to break bad habits
around the world,
and, Mr. Wonderful, I just --
I can't work with you.
Why not?
I'm just worried that if
we work together --
He doesn't --
You don't like him.
I do like him as a person,
but I feel like, as an investor
in the company,
it would be really bad.
Greiner:
Maneesh, you didn't want
an offer here today.
Did you really?
-I absolutely want an offer.
I absolutely want an offer.
-You just came in for exposure?
Okay, you got one, and why don't
you want the structure of
that offer? Why not?
It's the [sighs] The structure's
actually quite good.
Uh...
-It's the person.
It's the person.
I feel like...
♪♪
...I would take an offer from
anybody besides Mr. Wonderful.
♪♪
Maneesh, you're an [bleep]
Get the [bleep] out of here.
Oh!
Maneesh: Um, okay.
Well...if you --
Are you all out?
[Bleep] you.
We're all out.
Cuban: Done, Maneesh.
See ya.
All right, Sharks.
Thank you very much.
Wouldn't want to be ya.
♪♪
I had a tinge of regret
for rejecting the deal
with Mr. Wonderful,
but the truth is our company
is building something
much bigger than just money.
We're trying to change
human behavior,
and Kevin wouldn't be the right
partner for us to work with.
I'm telling you,
whether it was you
or me or Robert
or one of us,
he was gonna do that
to somebody.
It just happened to be
you were the last guy.
-Because it's talk.
-I realize he's a gold digger.
He's an idiot!
He's a con artist.
This technology has promise.
No, he thinks he's sincere.
It's not a technology, Kevin!
He's a con artist.
-Has problems or promise?
-Kevin, don't feel bad.
-I don't feel bad.
-Don't feel bad.